Drones are everywhere!
They're used in television, movies, toys,
military, construction, sports, manufacturing,
and more.
And the newest technology is even more advanced
than you know.
The official name for the remote controlled
"drones" we know and love/hate is UAVs or
unmanned aerial vehicles, though the military
calls them Unmanned Aerial Systems or UASs.
The word "drone" implies something which operates
on its own, though most military drones or
UAVs are simply remote controlled -- but for
the sake of simplicity we'll call them drones
anyway…
The first weaponized drone was flown in 1994
-- the Predator MQ-1; but advances in the
last 20 years have been incredible.
Take, for example, the largest drone around
today: a 757-sized UAV called Triton operated
by the U.S. Navy.
Its 130-foot wingspan and fuel efficiency
allows it to fly 2,000 nautical miles in a
mission, identify ships, de-ice its wings,
and navigate turbulence -- ALL without human
interaction.
The thing can even be struck by lightning
and still operate.
Most flying drones operate for 20 hours and
are pre-programmed to fly to a specific area
and look around, or piloted to a mission by
a person in a ground station.
The military controls these giant aircraft
from hundreds of miles away via satellite
communications, GPS and the aircraft's onboard
computers.
This combination of ground and space-based
systems can affect how long information takes
to get to the pilot -- Predators took a long
as five minutes to get detailed information,
making the UAV system extra important, but
today, the newest drones can provide 360 degree
video, infrared, and radar data: all live.
Most UASs include line-of-site control for
take-off and landing, and satellite control
during long flights and missions which would
go out of range of a tower or antenna.
Obviously direct control is faster, satellites
have a 1-second delay... but if somehow the
signal is lost from the human pilot, the drone
can be programmed to fly in circles, or return
to its take-off point.
It can even land on its own if it has to.
Drones aren't only airborne.
The drone boat is a true autonomous and artificially
intelligent helper boat.
These drone boats are programmed to swarm
targets without human instruction -- they
can network with each other, and though they're
unarmed, are supposed to isolate a craft or
intercept enemy fire without putting people
in harms way.
Another naval drone uses biomimicry technology
to look like sharks or fish!
These drones can operate in 10 inches of water
or dive to 300 feet either tethered to a ship,
or autonomously; only surfacing to communicate.
They're unarmed, but key for intelligence
gathering.
The future of drones is getting crazy.
Virtual Reality is coming, where pilots can
"look" through cameras and pilot aircraft
or boats like a video game.
It's already come to commercial drones used
for Star Wars pod-racing-style games.
But the U.S. Air Force is pulling out all
the stops with their "secret" space shuttle.
The X-37B launched in 2012 and orbited the
earth for 500 days autonomously, returning
and landing on its own in 2014.
No one knows what it's for… but it's technically
a drone.
And people allegedly spotted Northrop-Grumman's
flying wings over texas, a type of aircraft
rumored for a long while, even tested by NASA,
but still classified, if it exists at all.
Drones have advanced so much in 20 years…
will another 20 have them delivering pizzas,
filming football games, going to asteroids
and flying us around the globe.
Who knows, but one things for sure, they're
here to stay.
There is something that could dampen drones
in our time, if the people put their foot
down and stop their use in the military, but
it doesn't seem like that's going to happen.
For more check out TestTube for the Pros and
Cons of Drones in War here.
That being said, drones are machines, they're
not just for attacking, plenty of drones are
used for good!
Seeker has a whole episode about how drones
are making the world a better place.
Which you can see here!